Jim Gaffigan makes a good question he's
like why didn't Trump call anybody in
why didn't Trump just say get law
enforcement down there right now I think
it's fair to say that Trump was bumbling
quite a bit I don't think Trump had any
intention on anyone going into the
capital I think he genuinely had no idea
what's going on and I don't mean that he
didn't know there were people start
storming the capital on one side and
going in another I'm saying he did not
comprehend the situation well have you
you've read though that apparently after
his speech he told Secret Service to
drive him to the Capitol and they said
no we're taking you pretty sure that was
a fake story oh was that effect they
claimed that Trump like attacked the
driver well yeah it was exaggerated he
attacked the driver but what I what I
gar what I gathered from that was like
if Trump did actually want to go to the
Capitol and talk to these guys could
have been a totally different outcome if
Trump was there and he was like hey guys
we want to do this peacefully as he was
probably still speaking when they were
breaching the capitol grounds oh okay
right but either way if he had gotten
there he you know he could have ended it